hi everyone I'm nipple tattoos mad at
the world economic forum thank you to
everyone for participating in the World
Economic Forum on East Asia in Jakarta
I'm man with Athena and Jenny who've
been helping me in the social media
corner of the last couple of days how do
you guys think it's gone here it's very
fun fun fest we've met so many good
people in here and then they over
address some answer that is wearing
fashion expert very first group yeah its
religious just as your fans asking you
well thanks to all of you for following
us on Facebook Twitter YouTube
contributing your ideas to be asked
commuter series and contributing your
ideas across all the different channels
so thank you very much keep in touch and
we look forward to hearing more ok take
it right